all right speaking of cinco de mayo
celebrations and grab your margaritas or
coffee spiked coffee and get ready to
fart set
jc is live at downtown container park
with details
on the big fiesta going on there jc
rocky and kendall happy cinco de mayo to
you and happy cinco de mayo to everyone
watching and here's the great part
about this party it starts at five
o'clock so you have plenty of time to
get down here
to container park this is chelsea with
container park so first describe this
area people watching haven't been down
here what's container park all about
yeah so container park is a
family-friendly downtown destination
made out of shipping containers and
we've got a bunch of different small
businesses
restaurants bars and it's a great place
to kind of hang out you can take the
kids to the playground and there's live
music tonight yeah we have a mariachi
band later on tonight we will
oh this is so awesome the weather is
perfect there's no wind down here let's
go inside
what's the taco shop we're going into
right here so this is pinches tacos
there's one other location in vegas but
they've got tacos margaritas nachos
kind of anything you could want tonight
right you've got great taco specials
tonight we got margarita specials
tonight and later on before we go inside
and eat some tacos
we've got mechanical bowls later on
today right we do starting at five
o'clock you'll be able to ride a bull on
the lawn which i don't think we've ever
done before that's the only place in las
vegas i think tonight where you can ride
and you can eat tacos and ride a
mechanical bowl there you go
shall we go inside and have some tacos
it is cinco de mayo all right chelsea
asked for you
i guess lancia should go in next
all right so talk to me about the tacos
that we have inside here so pj's tacos
is actually doing 2.50
tacos all night tonight so we've got a
couple chicken i think a couple of
carnitas and then here's one of their
signature margaritas
what makes their margaritas so special
i've heard such great things about these
margaritas what makes them so special
they taste good
and obviously the amount of tequila is
that
you guys have a non-alcoholic one no
she's she's laughing at me there's no
non-alcoholic one all right i gotta try
when the tacos right so let's get in
that's on you here we go oh it looks so
good
this is what cinco de mayo is all about
right mexican heritage great food
margaritas
that is so good so everything kicks off
at five o'clock and goes until when
uh tonight we're actually going to
extend an hour so we'll be open until 11
pm
uh and then the band goes on at nine
bull ridings are at five and you can
come and drink and hang out till then
now for some reason you can't make it
down here tonight it is a school night
it's free to get in right
it's free to get in free again and if
you're doing this all weekend on
saturday right yeah so we're gonna have
another
live mariachi band on saturday and more
drink specials
all right kendall and rocky these tacos
are so good i can bring you some back to
this actually i'll send lance back to
the studio if you guys want some
yeah i mean is there even a question jc
we've been talking about the tacos and
your biceps the whole time
they said you did some push-ups right
oh bueno all right thank you so
let me just much the tacos really quick
yeah
thank you jc we'll check back in with
you later on in the show